It's been awful year for apple at least
by the company's high standards
and I have an uninspiring message for the
company's fans and investors
wondering when Apple's tide will turn:
Wait until
next year.
Apple's revenues declined for the last
two quarters and probably will continue
to fall for the next six months. The last
time apple sales dropped for 12 months
straight was 2001. Mark Zuckerberg was
still in high school.
Apple stock has also dropped twenty six
percent from an all-time high in
February 2015. The company's product
wizards are keeping busy but the next
year won't be a blockbuster. The newly
updated iPhones Apple will show off
at an event on wednesday
no matter what they're called will be
more like tweaked versions of the iPhone 6s
breaking with Apples pattern of
having significant updates in
even-numbered years. Also coming are
fresh models of some Mac computers and a
second generation Apple watch.
None of these products will be surprises
but they should help Apple sales grow
again least modestly after this holiday
season. The big hopes for a major sales
rebound are riding on 2017. Expectations
are building that Apple will pull out a
dramatically different iPhone a year
from now with a new type of super thin
screen that could spark a big wave of
new iPhone sales
it's been five years since Tim Cook took
over as Apple CEO and the company has
become even more financially successful
but it doesn't have a breakout new "wow"
product category under his watch.
Wait until next year isn't a great
rallying cry but it's the best Apple can do.